hey everybody it's Mike fried here with
on-call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week did I cut off the first minute of
that am I all right no yeah you want me
to start over again because everybody
loves hearing me say that again no yeah
all right this week we're talking about
cfmc control ia.l 2-3.5.9 sometimes you
start recording a video and you just
know it's going to be incredibly awesome
like when you chug carbonated water
right before you start reading and then
you screw up the intro
um but hey it's YouTube and honestly
listening to me blubber my videos is
probably better than the actual
compliance content right so hey cmfc
control
ia.l2-3.5.9 allow temporary password
reuse uh excuse me allow temporary
password my goal I'm going to scrub
every three words and then make a joke
about it they'll take 15 words
making this script way longer than it
really needs to be uh so much for a
production schedule this week we're
talking about
cmmccontrolia.l2-3.5.9 allow temporary
password use for system logons with an
immediate change to pass to a permanent
password
[Music]
thank you
all right so hey if you're a defense
contractor who's feeling overwhelmed
tired and alone trying to understand all
this cmmc dfars and nist sp171
compliance stuff on top of an already
colossal workload well I've got great
news for you you found your home here at
on-call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on-call compliance hero or
just a burping blunder just kidding all
right let's jump into it
cmmccontrolia.l2-3.5.9
allow temporary password use for system
logons with an immediate change to a
permanent password anytime I see the
word immediate and it's like an official
word immediate not like I put the word
immediate in there I feel like I need to
say like immediate like with a lot of
immediate emphasis on it
I don't know if you guys feel the same
way but they immediately like there's no
delay in changing your password if
you're changing your password
has to be immediate there's no delaying
there's no going to the bathroom in the
middle of changing your password
apparently anyway so yes in systems
which contain cui we are essentially
having to Define how password reset
functionality will work uh the way this
control is described describes the only
real secure way of making sure that When
an Admin resets a password that they
that they won't be able to continue
knowing what the password is in the
future so again here's the danger all
right you reset the password as an admin
because you get a password reset request
but then you know what it is so you have
to sort of be able to immediately
mandate that they change it
uh again this is a critical security
best practice it should be built into
most systems and to describe more let's
jump into what the assessors are
actually looking for here so only one
assessment point it's a pretty simple
control determine if an immediate change
to a permanent password is required when
a temporary password is used for system
logon again we would give an answer
saying hey this is implemented all in
all cases of password reset users must
change their temporary passwords the
first time they're logged in again this
is more of a demonstrate kind of control
you're gonna have to actually show an
assessor how to actually you know how
your system works and verify that it
actually does and hey at on-call we work
with defense contractors just like you
who have had this dvars nist itar and
cmmc compliant stuff dropped into apps
like a seagull on a sunny day we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps great areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance as your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance Bureau
can do for you
uh if you're looking for more help
getting compliant you're in the right
place because our compliance experts are
always on call for you you can visit
cmmc compliance secrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button if this is like let's be honest
all right let's take a pause if this is
like your fourth video today that you've
watched and you haven't subscribed
you owe me a click you owe me just it's
like check this out right you move your
hand like this far down that's how much
effort is involved and then a lot of
effort is involved in doing that just
practice do do it do it one on the like
one of the Subscribe one on the like one
of the Subscribe that's it that's the
motion that helps us out it's a big deal
it's such a big deal I think I'll pause
the video tell you more about it I'm
just kidding but but in all seriousness
I love it that you watch our videos and
we have to have this conversation
because you may not have subscribed and
if you haven't subscribed
I just I just want you to know that we
love you it's okay you can be wrong but
the right thing to do is to subscribe
don't don't keep don't do it don't keep
taking our content for free without a
subscription it's free the subscription
is free you have to pay for it you know
the day I found out that you can
subscribe to somebody's Channel for free
and it didn't cost money and it actually
helped them out I was like I'm the most
charitable guy in the world I'll
subscribe to everybody because it makes
everybody happy there's actually it
doesn't cost me anything this motion it
cost me this motion so if it's been a
while I've been watching our videos I
love you I just want you to subscribe so
I can know that we're actually doing
good out there you know our
subscribership has actually been growing
big time lately and I just also like
while we're on this little tangent I
just want to thank you thanks for
staying into the end because I know you
could do a little Skippy thing but but
the Skippy thing probably just winds up
having you watch a commercial about
something not relevant to getting
compliant like speaking of Skippy maybe
it's a commercial of Skippy peanut
butter because you ran out this morning
I saw it in your fridge
so really at the end of the day I just
want you to subscribe because if you do
subscribe you get way more entertaining
diatribes like this and they're kind of
fun to do
and it drives my editor knots all right
so uh yeah leave me some comments below
if you want to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
guess what you'll see me on the next one
because nobody else wants to stand in
front of this camera and tell you all
about compliance
[Music]
all right